at the risk of asking the totally wrong
person this question uh what advice
would you give to young people today
in high school and college about how to
have a successful career
or career they're proud of or maybe have
a life that they're proud of ooh
well first of all you got to be
you got to want a life you're proud of
not everybody has any integrity and
people just a lot of people just want
short money
i want to feel good
look good
right now i want to do molly boom i'll
feel good you know but you should
space it out you should it's almost like
saving money so you can use it later
nobody wants to save money what do they
say like 11 of america actually has
money saved a thousand dollars or some
it's wildly low
everybody wants it now now
what do you call immediate gratification
i think
the key to
happiness and satisfaction is working
for something
even if it's uh it's like a baby if you
could have a baby in five minutes if a
woman you gotta you in her and
she had a baby up five minutes boom
newborn healthy
i think you'd be more likely to throw it
away
if you could make it that quick it's the
fact that you spent nine months back
breaking the labor the lactating the
ripped placenta and the hymen or
whatever the
that's what makes you love it and i
think it's the same with comedy or or
making money or whatever look at these
kids who who like child stars they all
become heroin addicts at like 22 because
they've just their sensors are burned
out they're pleasure sensors you didn't
have to earn it
i think earning it is a big part of life
and uh always try to do better try to do
more try to learn new things hey i'm
bored i life sucks like play the piano
then you chooch but you you won't do it
because it takes effort and failure and
all that but that's the good part yeah
and i know it's hard to see
so i think that's uh that's a good
good key to life is work hard it's
something you care about and then
love the result
the hard work the journey is actually
way more important than just getting
something everybody wants to go on
amazon i got a package then you feel
good for 10 seconds and
all right let's go on amazon again and
then you're just it's just a dumb cycle
of you being
disgusting and gluttonous
so work for it
everybody wants to take steroids and
just boop i'm buff why'd you point at me
well i'm just rushing or what
i saw the the icarus yeah but no i'm not
saying you're on roids i'm just you'd be
way bigger but uh i'm just saying you
know
work for something and then i would also
young people eat early
eat early i know a guy who kind of
got cancelled or whatever and he had an
out early but he tried to get by and he
tried to ride it
and it all came crumbling down but if he
had eaten it early like yeah i up
i did that
whatever it was
he would have he would have just kind of
been been on for a month and then
it would have gone away but now it's his
whole identity and that sucks so eat
early and i know it's hard to see
what i mean early i'm in the present but
look ahead look back this time will pass
i mean look at high school high school
was the biggest thing in our lives oh my
god this exam susie q hates me the
football player beat me up oh i'll never
recover now you don't even think about
high school it's just a blip in your
dumb life you know and that's what this
is now this will just be a blip so
remember that
and work towards something
and uh
work hard and
care about the result if the result
isn't good try it again and failure is
not always bad failure we look at
failure as this
end-all be-all my life's over i failed
but failure's really just learning
so that's something so in summary
eat early and eat often yes
all right
mark norman eat s
that's the escalated quickly all right
you